[Music]
foreign
Landmark reporters found the
Metropolitan pleased to be
institutionally racist sexist and
homophobic the author baroness Louise
Casey has warned that the Met can no
longer presume that it has the
permission of the people of London to
police them and so the force may need to
be broken up our home Affairs the editor
Jason Farrell has the story and a
warning his report contains some flash
photography from the very beginning
londoners and particularly women have
been failed this review borne out of the
murder of Sarah everard found that even
the policing of her vigil further
damaged confidence
but it also reveals the lack of faith is
shared by many officers one says rape
convictions are so bad it may as well be
legalized there are stories of rape
tests being ruined because of broken
fridges and a female officer who
reported being raped by another officer
who was then forced to work with him
even as we publish this report there
hasn't been a change across the whole of
policing that says anybody that's got
domestic abuse on their record or
anybody that has indecent exposure isn't
automatically removed from the ability
to be a police officer so I think they
should be of course they should be
the report finds a bullying culture
underpins the Met's problems it tells of
initiation rituals with Junior officers
urinated on and one sexually assaulted
in a shower it's ghastly isn't it you
sit down and read that report and it
generates a whole series of emotions it
generates sort of sort of anger
frustration embarrassment
it generates some pride as well which
may sound odd but it's our men and women
who care about the policing of London
who've given most the evidence for that
report to Louise Casey which is a
testament to their commitments when
police officer Wayne cousins murdered
Sarah everard his case prompted the
first victim to report serial rapist
David Carrick and one of his victims
told us that she was left so traumatized
she feared all uniformed police officers
I would just freeze stop breathing in my
mind I was just straight away thinking
they're going to harm me
what does the police need to do to win
back your trust
I think they need to
to go through the force and vet every
single guy that is working there
yeah
and even if there was a mention of a
minor domestic violence argument to
fully investigate it among many
recommendations the report calls for a
new independent team to deal with
misconduct cases end-to-end vetting of
police officers during their time in
service and disbanding the Parliamentary
and diplomatic protection unit of which
both cousins and Carrick were members
it's nearly 25 years since the
MacPherson review found that the police
was institutionally racist now not only
are they bound to be racist but also
misogynistic and homophobic what is the
government going to do about this
well the report is clear that there are
systemic and chronic problems with
leadership and culture and what we need
to do is change the culture change the
practice and change the systems in place
that are running and regulating the met
and that depends on the leadership
Louise Casey says leadership has till
now repeatedly failed and it is
leadership she hopes that will in Time
Repair the damage Jason Farrell Sky News
police chief and that's Samara early
hello thank you for joining us on the
program this morning broken rotten
institutionally racist misogynistic and
homophobic
how did you sleep last night
this is a very very worrying report I
returned to policing after a few years
out last September recognizing the
challenges we face and I'm resolved that
we will reform policing and I know the
vast majority of my people are this is a
very upsetting read you can't read this
report and not be upset embarrassed and
humbled by some of what's been said the
one thing that's heartening in it for me
the evidence in this report comes from
the men and women in my organization who
care deeply who want us to do better who
want us to be different and it's with my
resolve and their resolve that we will
reform the culture of the met and we
will do better for the people of London
do you accept the full findings of the
report
we accept the findings of the report as
I say it's a it's deeply worrying Mark
do you expect
we accept the I accept the findings of
the reports absolutely
the full findings of the report
I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand you
know exactly what it means we're talking
about your suggestions that you don't
accept that your force is
institutionally races
I absolutely accept the diagnosis that
Louise Casey comes up with we have
racist misogynist and homophobes in the
organization and it's not just about
individuals we have systemic failings
management failings and cultural
failings the reason and I respect Louise
using that term the reason I don't use
it um I think it's a very ambiguous term
your your viewers would have different
interpretations what it means
to Mark so Mark if I may I purposefully
looked it up in the dictionary this
morning uh institutionally means uh
convention or Norm in a culture and
that's what Louise Casey thinks is
happening in the met you tell me why
it's not
so that you've proven my point I'm sorry
to say because
um the definition you pulled out is not
the one that William McPherson used it's
not the one that Louise Casey uses
everyone uses different definitions it's
pointless arguing about definitions we
have a real problem here we have
misogyny homophobia and racism in the
organization and we're going to root it
out I've already grown our capability to
do that we're absolutely determined to
take this on we're removing officers
more quickly we're tackling these issues
and meanwhile Dana Diaz I've got the
offices of the force who are coming
forward and they are absolutely
determined to tackle this the vast
majority are as embarrassed and angered
by this as I am and we want to make a
difference okay well that was certainly
the phrase that we use was used in an
English dictionary if you want to take
um
humbridge at that I'm not sure whether
you do or not but there we go baroness
Casey pinned the primary uh blame on
past leadership you were previously
assistant commissioner and held very
senior roles at the Met between
2011 and 2018 what responsibility do you
accept
I think all of us who've LED in policing
need to reflect on why we didn't see the
scale of this earlier and I certainly
I'm certainly doing that as I said I've
had four years out of policing and I've
come back because I'm absolutely
determined that we need to tackle this I
think you'll find up in more outspoken
on the need for police reform over the
last six months than
um probably any police leader for
decades so we are already putting in
place a turnaround plan we're making big
strides already luis's recommendations
will massively influence our thinking
and the plans we have ahead to reform
for policing for London as we strengthen
our work in neighborhoods as we improve
the response to victims and as we tackle
the toxic individuals in the
organization need to removing
so you are questioning your position
this morning
yeah
I came I came back six months ago to
tackle these issues and I've been
absolutely clear that that's what's
required and I think Louise Casey has
has backed the fact that we're up for
this well no she hasn't she said that
she puts the primary blame at past
leadership and that's you
she's also spoken about the changing
tone that the new leadership has brought
in the organization we're absolutely
determined to deliver the transformation
required that's what I returned policing
for and that's what we're doing as I say
we're building no book leasing we're
strengthening our response to victims
and we're rooting out these individuals
who've undermined us so so badly we're
sacking officers at a greater rate and
we're and the information is coming from
our own staff who want this to change
okay we only have a limited amount of
time 34 000 police officers how
confident can you be that among those
ranks there aren't others this morning
that are capable of rape and murder of
innocent young women on the Streets of
London
we are systematically going through
please answer my questions if you would
how confident can you be that you don't
have other rapists in your ranks
I'm doing everything possible to
identify if there's any risk of that
whatsoever we're reveetting all of our
officers reviewing all the old cases of
allegations against officers I'm doing
everything possible to remove to spot
anybody and remove them who proposes any
risk to the public
are there still officers working for you
this morning that are guilty of domestic
abuse and indecent exposure
and there's one reported in the um daily
mail recently who's guilty of a decent
exposure that's why we that's why we're
reviewing all of our cases we're
bringing a new vetting method to um to
remove officers who fail vetting I've
been asking the Home Secretary and the
Prime Minister for new powers to improve
police regulations to make it easier to
deal with these issues we are absolutely
determined to tackle the toxic
individuals who remain in this
organization who shouldn't be here
there's no doubt about that whatsoever
so you acknowledge to Mark there are
others that could very well be others
there are toxic individuals in this
organization who are in the process of
removing now
okay who could be responsible for a
domestic abuse indecent exposure perhaps
even rape
I'm not going to get into if split some
babies we've got toxic individuals some
of whom have been involved who've got
concerns about their
predatory behavior we've got people
suspended we've got people under
investigation We are rooting them out of
this organization
I've committed by the end of March to
give an update on the work we've been
doing on this and I'll publish that then
okay so you can give us an idea at this
stage of how many you're looking at
I'm gonna I'm gonna give a full update
on that at the end of March we're
working through this work systematically
an easier one I mean will you just span
the Parliamentary and diplomatic
protection unit as suggested by the
report uh cousins and Carrick both
members of that
so um the report says we should
effectively disband it we're going to do
everything possible to reform and change
um
recommend as much as possible
um I have to protect Parliament tomorrow
I have to protect embassies tomorrow I
can't just take all those offices away
and and stop doing that we're going to
do everything possible to change the
culture in that in in that department
and with the Vigor and um and and
radicalism that Louise Coast is calling
for so not following the recommendations
of the report then
we're absolutely following the
recommendations and we've discussed this
with noise
she says effectively disband this so
you're not quoting the port correctly
she's effectively spanned it we're gonna
and she wants us to be as radical as we
possibly can do in changing it she
absolutely said I've had this
conversation with her face to face she
absolutely understands that we can't
break it up overnight and still protect
Parliament but she wants us to be as
radical as we can be in changing the
culture and changing the people in there
we've already brought in new leadership
as a senior level half the sergeants are
different we're looking to we're
bringing in lots of new recruits into it
to change the culture there's a lot
going on there and we're going to
reflect on those recommendations see
what more we can do yeah um reflect on
them okay uh not necessarily adopt them
um as met Police Commissioner you have
to rely on the that's asleep
on policing nine million londoners by
consent the report says that that
pillion principle is at risk
if that is the case how can londoners
feel safe with you in charge this
morning
so I have a thousands tens of thousands
of officers going out day after day
they're out there today protecting
londoners they're arresting dangerous
people they're protecting the vulnerable
and they're doing a fantastic job this
report is deeply worrying and you're
right
um fixing my consent in London has been
damaged by recent events trust has
declined over the last four years that's
what we're here to do to turn that round
londoners can have absolute confidence
that we're here to turn that round and
improve the service that they get we
stay right this is Earth
how can they be when you say you don't
know whether you've got rapists
murderers people that abuse women within
your ranks and you can't even talk in
more detail about that this morning we
have to wait for yet another report
I said I'm absolutely clear we're doing
everything we possibly can do to look
back because those cases those four
cases of cousins
so those awful cases of cousins and
Carrick what they show is that our
systems have not been strong enough at
spotting toxic individuals dangerous
individuals within our ranks for that
reason we've taken everyone's details in
the organization and we're working for
you reviewing them against all the
National Police databases
the mark That's you you were there at
the force for years that's you you're
the past leadership you have to accept
responsibility for this and fall on your
sword
um we have we have gone through all the
details of all of our officers and
reviewing them against National Police
databases we're looking at past
allegations to make sure they haven't
been badly investigated and we haven't
made mistakes and the people who
shouldn't be here we're working through
it systematically so londoners can be
happy that we look for every possible
risk in the organization remove those
individuals we're removing organizations
are going to be very happy with you this
morning sir
well I hope they see that we're
absolutely resolved and we're determined
to take these issues on the identified
in this report okay I'm going to be
talking to your boss a bit later on
let's see what he has to say for now
thanks very much indeed for joining us
on the program I know a difficult day
ahead thank you very much thank you
hi thoughts okay
well it was a it was one of those press
conferences I think where everyone's jaw
dropped yesterday when Louise Casey just
gave the full details of the review and
it wasn't just the fact that she talked
about institutional racism and sexism
and homophobia it was also actually the
pressures that she was talking about
that the police were under and
particularly how they had failed women
uh in rape cases and I think the symbol
of that was when she talked about
fridges for example that were broken
that had rape kits in them that had
sometimes they were so stuffed they took
three people to try and shut the door or
the door had to be strapped shut
I think my jaw hit the floor when she
said that in one of those fridges there
was a lunch box discovered uh in 2022
during the heat wave
some of those fridges one of those
fridges broke and a load of rape cases
were ruined by the fact that the rate
kits were destroyed
and that's the kind of thing she's
talking about when she's talking about
the failures and in the sense
institutional sexism it's not giving
women a real opportunity to get their
cases heard in court due to police
failings
um and also within the force women
having sexist comments still in this day
and age dealing with that kind of thing
and the fact that and and she couldn't
quite get over this point that if
someone had exposed themselves on a
train for example that they could still
be a police officer that that was still
possible and she looked at the room and
she said how many of you would have kept
your jobs in that situation and I think
the overriding thing for me was that she
was feeling the weight of the fact that
there had been so many reports into the
Metropolitan Police and this is the
point you were touching on there with
Mark Rowley that there have there hasn't
had to change from the McPherson review
all the way back nearly 25 years ago 25
years ago the fact that that said that
the police was institutionally racist
and here was a woman saying it's not
it's still racist but it's also sexist
it's also homophobic well he wouldn't
accept the word institutional yeah and
she made the point that the she
described what she described as Hollow
promises
fake change a failure to accept the
truth and what she was really hoping for
and this came across really strongly in
the press conference was
please just take this on the chin accept
that these failings exist and then we
can get on because if the murder of a
Woman by a police officer doesn't affect
change then nothing will so she is
disappointed that Mark Rowley hasn't
accepted institutional I would say
though that she has said that she does
have confidence that he will bring
reform she did think that this new
leadership could potentially make a
difference but whether it will make
enough new world leadership new old Leo
like you like you make the point he's
been there before but she had some
confidence that there would be changed
but I'm what she's calling for is very
very radical okay let's see what happens
when I thanks very much indeed Jason
thank you well throughout the program
today you have the chance
um to have your say on our top story
this morning we want to know how much
Faith do you have in the metropolitan
police broken rotten institutionally
racist misogynistic and homophobic
that's baroness Casey's verdict in her
report into Britain's largest Force you
can tweet me if you would like to at
Cape early with your thoughts
now Bryce Johnson's written defense of
dining streets parties is due to be
published later on today the committee
looking into whether the former prime
minister misled Parliament is expected
to publish a dossier which it received
late yesterday is what we were told and
tomorrow Mr Johnson faces a
cross-examination by the committee's MPS
which is expected to last up to five
hours uh full coverage of that will be
here on Sky News
more than 100 people have been arrested
during a night of protests in Paris
against the retirement age rising from
62 to 64. rubbish bins were set on fire
during scuffles with the police the
government narrowly survived two
no-confidence motions after pushing the
unpopular reform through Parliament
without a vote by MPS let's set talk to
Mark Harper should we know the transport
secretary representing the government
this morning lots to talk about you've
had some successes we'll come to that
first of all your reaction to this
report into the Metropolitan Police well
the summary is it's a very shocking and
troubling report and Louise Casey sets
out very clearly lots of very specific
examples about the things that have gone
wrong in the net and the things that
need to be put right and I know that
from the government's point of view the
Home Secretary has made it clear that
she backed the commissioner to make the
changes that are necessary and Louise
Casey herself says that all of us in
politics should back the commissioner
and his Deputy in the changes that
they're going to have to make in the Met
to make sure it's a police force fit to
police London and the national
responsibility but she criticizes
previous leadership and he was part of
that previous leadership well she said
in the summary of her report that she
believes that the commissioner and his
Deputy are capable of making the changes
necessary that they understand the scale
of the challenge she also says that she
thinks they'll be successfully making
those changes and she herself backs them
to do that and she wants us to back them
as well and I think that's really
important that we do so they've got a
big job of work on their house yes he
does the Home Secretary has made it
clear that the commissioner has her
support in making the changes that are
necessary to get the Met into the sort
of police force we want to see in London
even though londoners don't
well London is at the moment quite
understandably have lost a lot of
confidence because of all of the the
terrible events that have taken place so
the commissioner has a very large job of
work to do uh he was appointed late last
year and the government supports him in
the changes that he's going to have to
make to get the Met into a fit shape
that it needs to be to serve London well
look I think he is going to work on this
very quickly there's already work but in
place the Home Secretary for example
commissioned a review which is going to
report in the not too distant future
about most of these reviews is what my
viewers will be saying at home and you
know we had one from Mcpherson review 25
years ago and was still according to the
Police Service in in London is still
institutional well look one of the
quarter of a century one of the big
changes for example that's called out in
the report is how you get rid of bad
officers and the process at the moment
is there's an instant an independent
panel the commissioner doesn't have the
power to dismiss bad officers and the
homosexually commissioned an urgent
review into what changes need to be made
and that that's one of the
recommendations is in the report from
Louise Casey let's talk about rmt union
members at Network rail voted to accept
a revised pay offer why did it take so
long well I know you'd have to ask the
rmt why they took such a long period of
time to put it to their members but look
from the moment I became transport
secretary last October I tried to change
the the tone of the debate we were
having with the unions I met with all of
the rail union leaders and I made sure a
fair reasonable payoff was put
um to the to the unions to put for that
to their staff now I'm really pleased
that rmt members that work for Network
rail voted with a 90 turnout three over
three quarters of them accepted that
fair and reasonable payoff though now on
network rail we've resolved the dispute
what I want to see happen is for the rmt
to put what is broadly the same value
offer to their members that work on the
train operating companies call off the
strikes next week and let their members
make a decision about whether they think
that's a fair and reasonable payoffer
um and then we can resolve the dispute
for the rmt members on the rail system
entirely for the benefit of passengers
what was wrong with the tone previous to
your tenure well I think talking to the
trade unions I think is helpful you'll
see that the government overall has been
doing that with other trade unions and I
think you get a better outcome and I'm
pleased that we got fair and reasonable
acknowledge that the attack was
uh inappropriate previously well when I
became transport secretary the Prime
Minister gave me certain things to get
done one of them was to try and resolve
these disputes I approached it in the
way you know my own way about how I want
to approach these things I thought I
wanted to change the tone I wanted to
sit down with the Trade union leaders
and I wanted to make sure we had a fair
and reasonable offer and their staff
have accepted that for a reason but
often I think it's fair for the people
that work on the railways I think it's
fair for passengers I think it's fair
for the taxpayer just underline that if
I may you tweeted that you were pleased
that Network rails rmt members have
voted to accept the offer that the
government worked hard to facilitate
um Grant shops your predecessor said it
was not for the government to intervene
well look the government I think had to
facilitate the offer it was made by
Network rather than the train operating
companies well look the the you know
your viewers may not realize this but
you know post pandemic all of the train
operating companies uh work on contracts
that are set by me uh taxpayer has put a
huge amount of support into the you have
to acknowledge that the government took
the wrong tax previously look and you've
managed to get a deal over the line I've
taken the steps that I took since I
became transport search and set out the
changes I thought needed to be made and
I'm pleased that that rmt members have
voted for that deal you know my job is
to do what I think is right for the
passenger right for the tax deal could
have been done much earlier well look I
I don't think speculating about what
might have happened in the past I don't
know look I've done what I've done since
I became transportation I've taken the
steps that I thought were necessary I've
changed the tone of the debate and I
think as far as this dispute is
concerned we've we've sorted out on
network rain I hope we can sort it out
on the train operating companies to
Source our normal strikes planned there
are on the train operating companies and
I said I want the rmt to put what is
broadly the same deal so they're members
who work on the train operating
companies and ask their members if they
want to accept that deal as their
members on network railoverwhelmed we
did yesterday put these strikes on the
30th of March and the 1st of April can
be averted well I hope so if if the rmt
are willing to put that deal to their
members they could call the strikes off
today put that deal to their members and
I hope we could then resolve the
certainly the dispute as far as the rmt
is concerned completely two quick
questions if I may uh front of the
papers this morning potholes everywhere
what are you going to do to sort them
out well you always want to know we'd
spend billions of pounds a year on
maintaining the road Network and I was
very pleased that the chancellor found
an extra 200 million pounds in the
budget which has been distributed to
councils across the country to help deal
with potholes uh it's a problem
particularly this time of the year and I
want to make sure we continue investing
in the road Network we announced our
Capital spending we're investing 20
billion pounds in Road and rail networks
across the country
um well look you've got a balance
investment in the road Network for
drivers and bus users but you've also
got to balance it with the interest of
the taxpayer and it's the the job of
government to get that balance right I
think we have got that balance right but
we want to make sure we keep investing
improving our rates Just Before I Let
You Go Northern Ireland dup said not
sure about this deal after all certainly
certain aspects of it the ERG the
European research group I've got a news
conference lay later on they're likely
to reject it as well what does that mean
for the deal now well look I think most
people accept in fact I think even the
dup in their statement yesterday
accepted that the Windsor framework
which the Prime Minister negotiated is a
significant Improvement on the Northern
Ireland protocol got changes I think
that most people didn't expect the prime
minister to get I hope that the dup in
time will accept the deal they obviously
aren't going to support it this week but
I think the vast majority of my
colleagues will it's clearly an
improvement it deals with well I don't
know what they're going to do but look
it's an improvement on where we were
before it solves lots of the Practical
problems for the people of Northern
Ireland they should be at the
centerpiece of of this that's why the
Prime Minister negotiated the deal and I
hope that as many members of parliament
as possible will support it when we vote
on one aspect of it in the House of
Commons tomorrow good to see you thanks
very much thank you thank you
um we'll be looking at the paper review
for you in just a moment or two but
first the White House is called on
China's president Xi Jinping to urge
Vladimir Putin to end Russia's war in
Ukraine as the two meet in Moscow
president XI is the first world leader
to visit the Russian leader since the
international criminal court issued an
arrest warrant for him over alleged war
of crimes in Ukraine we'll have more on
that with Helen Anne in just a moment or
two in fact let's listen to it now
we're expecting the two leaders to sit
down for more formalized talks today
ahead of a state dinner later tonight
and potentially even a joint statement
to the press as well we understand that
yesterday uh president XI and Putin
spoke informally for about four and a
half hours but of course the eyes of the
world will be on these two men for the
next couple of days and particularly on
whether they come up with any sort of
proposal any sort of deal that might
pertain to that all-important context
the crisis the war in Ukraine uh China
president XI has always said that he is
going in to this meeting as a peacemaker
he wants to be seen as a Statesman in
this he says China is one of the only
powers that has not got involved that
hasn't supplied arms to either sides and
that could broker such a peace deal the
West raised some eyebrows at that of
course because China has been helping
Russia financially and certainly
diplomatically as well and many will
look at the last 24 hours and say that
the body language the choreography the
words that have been chosen have been
extremely warm and extremely friendly
and in that context many might ask can
China reasonably still claim to be a
neutral party in this because remember
president XI has actually never spoken
to president zelenski of Ukraine
although such a phone call might happen
this week but look there is a lot at
stake because also any potential
proposal of some sort of Deal or
potentially some sort of ceasefire is
unlikely to be acceptable to Ukraine
it's unlikely to be acceptable to the
west and that is because it would likely
be on Russia's terms because remember
the context to all this is that China
and Russia are close friends they share
geography they share some culture and
crucially they share a neutral deep
distrust of America and the west and
that is the bigger geopolitical context
within this within which this should all
be seen
three unions representing teachers and
school leaders who've called on ofsted
to pause inspections urging the Watchdog
to reflect on the impact they have on
the well-being of Staff after the death
of a head teacher Ruth Perry who was the
head of caversham primary school in
Reading took her own life in January
while waiting for an assessment after a
school was downgraded from outstanding
to inadequate either is here with us
what a terrible story over good morning
morning yeah very tragic this Ruth Perry
I was 53 she'd been a teacher for 32
years worked at this Primary School in
reading for 13 years but took her own
life as you say in January after this
ofsted inspection an inspection that saw
her school's reading go from outstanding
which is the best to inadequate which is
the worst of the four possible ratings
there will be an inquest um to look at
the full circumstances around her death
later this year but her family have
already said in a statement that they're
in no doubt her death was a direct
result of that inspection blaming what
they call a fatally flawed system that
they want to see overhauled so if from
this tragedy we now have this wider
route between schools and the schools
Watchdog ofsted with three education
unions calling this morning for ofsted
inspections to be paused suspended this
week I'm not sure that's going to happen
at the moment with ofsted saying in a
statement that they are deeply saddened
by Ruth Perry's death but they haven't
addressed Union's demands department for
Education have also issued a statement
kind of reminding everyone that it is a
legal requirement for these inspections
to go ahead so it'll be interesting to
hear what Jeff Barton has to say later
on on the show he's the head of one of
those unions yes and you're going to be
speaking to him later I am for now
thanks very much indeed if you have been
affected by this story and want to talk
to someone then there is always the
option to be able to do that
um Joe at samaritans.org 116123-116-123
as I said you can also email them Joe
samaritans.org
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
very nice
things will feel more spring-like this
week mild but changeable with showers or
longer Spells Of Rain
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now London is getting some new residents
who could help tackle climate change the
um we'll be telling you more about those
little chaps the Emir City card has
announced plans to reintroduce beavers
to West London after 400 years Paradise
fields in greenford will be transformed
into a wetland to promote a more
biodiverse ecosystem beavers were once
found throughout Britain but were hunted
to Extinction in the 16th century
looking at our top stories for you this
morning a review of The Metropolitan
Police to surround the forces
institutionally racist sexist and
homophobic and suggested it may need to
be split up
president XI has promoted China as a
peacemaker during his visit first visit
actually to Russia since the invasion of
Ukraine
and teaching unions have called for
ofsted to pause School inspections after
a head teacher took her own life
prime minister Rishi sunak is facing a
possible conservative Rebellion after
the dup said they would oppose his
brexit deal on Northern Ireland
[Music]
earlier on this hour actually I spoke to
the leader the commissioner the boss of
the Metropolitan Police it's been a
damning report about his officers what's
he going to do about it
so Mark do you accept the full findings
of the report
we accept I accept the findings of the
report absolutely
the full findings report
I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand you
know exactly what it means to Mark we're
talking about your suggestions that you
don't accept that your force is
institutionally racist
completely accept the diagnosis that
Louise Casey comes up with we have
racist misogynists and home firms in the
organization and it's not just about
individuals we have systemic failings
management failings and cultural
failings the reason and I respect Louise
using that term the reason I don't use
it I think it's a very ambiguous term
your your viewers would have different
interpretations what it means
right to Mark so Mark if I may I
purposefully looked it up in the
dictionary this morning institutionally
means convention or Norm in a culture
and that's what Louise Casey thinks is
happening in the met you tell me why
it's not
so that you've proven my point I'm sorry
to say because
um the definition you pulled out is not
the one that William McPherson used it's
not the one that Louise Casey uses
everyone uses different definitions it's
pointless arguing about definitions we
have a real problem here we have
misogyny homophobia and racism in the
organization and we're going to root it
out
that's what my dictionary said now
police in New York have been putting up
barricades after Donald Trump called on
supporters to protect against what he
says his is his imminent arrest a grand
jury has been investigating the former
president's alleged hush money payment
to the porn star Stormy Daniels James
Matthews hasmore
the word unprecedented underpins Donald
Trump's political career that won't
change if and when he faces criminal
charges here he'll be the first former
president to do so it promises to be
quite the spectacle inside and outside
the courtroom the NYPD have been
erecting barriers in the streets around
here mindful of the potential for
protest as encouraged by Donald Trump
himself yesterday some supporters were
out on the street albeit in small
numbers
the potential crime being looked at
relates to the adult film actress Stormy
Daniels and an alleged Affair that
Donald Trump had with her just days
before the 2016 election which he won he
feared she was going to go public so his
lawyer paid her hush money that was then
falsified when it was put through the
books of the Trump organization if the
indictment is Donald Trump will face
routine criminal procedure here complete
with fingerprints and mug shot quite the
come down for the former president
plotting a comeback
so could president Trump be indicted
today and stay tuned to Sky News for
more on that more now though on calls
from three unions representing teachers
and school leaders for ofsted to pause
inspections this week urging the
Watchdog to reflect on the impact they
have on the well-being of Staff Ruth
Perry who is the head at cavership
Primary School in Reading killed herself
in January while waiting for an
assessment which gave her school the
lowest possible rating let's get more on
this should we join now by the General
Secretary of the association of school
and college leaders Jeff Barton hi Jeff
good to see you as always tragic tragic
tragic story but can ofsted really be
held responsible
I think we have to be really careful
about that so I I can talk broadly about
ofsted and School inspection from
experience
this case highlights however the very
high stakes nature that we've got of
inspection where you know if you're a
head teacher for example you will spend
your Sunday night your Monday night your
Tuesday night and up to Wednesday
lunchtime worrying about whether ofsted
will come in the next day not because
inspection is a bad thing but because
the consequences of it can be a very bad
thing so for example if a school has
moved from outstanding to inadequate
like this one that we're hearing about
then your school will be taken over by a
trust
and you will worry that you lose your
own job and we're a trade Union we know
that people do lose their jobs doesn't
always happen but even the fear of that
is something I think most parents would
think it's out of all proportion I think
what what this highlights this case
highlights is that we are
putting too much pressure on the very
people in our communities who are
looking after our children what's the
alternative
I think the alternative is still to have
an inspection system I mean essentially
if taxpayers are paying for State
education so you want an inspection
system that comes in and holds a mirror
up to the school
the problem is the consequences of
reducing something as complex as a
school to a single grade if you're an
outstanding school all kinds of good
things will happen to you all kinds of
extra resources will come your way if
you're an inadequate school as I've said
you worry about that and in particular
those schools in the most challenging
areas that need the best teachers and
best leaders to want to go and work in
them why would you do that if you were
afraid of what the consequences might be
and therefore a really simple thing we
could do is to take away the overarching
grade so instead of reducing a school to
a single word why don't we say to
parents here's what the school is
distinctively doing well and here are
the things that we as inspectors have
talked to the leadership team that they
could be doing better and we will come
back and we will call out those schools
that aren't good enough and give them
extra support that would seem to be a
very Humane very sensible way of running
an inspection system instead of what
we've got at the moment which is
oversimplifying something as complex as
education to to single word grades what
if there was more
um
notice that
that specters were coming to the school
would that help
there's a debate about that you could as
a parent say I don't want the school to
have any notice I just want the
inspectors to turn up like a health and
safety inspector turning up at a
restaurant on the other hand that does
for someone like me who represents
School leaders imply a lack of trust and
one of the things that we're talking
about with the department for education
is should there be a different notice
period at the very least so that I know
that this year I'm not going to be
inspected as a school so that you as one
of my teachers can focus on the most
important stuff not getting ready for
ofsted inspections but focusing on
becoming a better teacher marking work
learning how to improve one of the
things we're calling for is can we have
the windows of when inspection are going
to happen
clearer in order that we can then take
some of the pressure and some of the
workload of teachers and head teachers I
think that would be eminently sensible
and I think the call to pause ofsted is
really simply to say are there some
lessons to be learned from this tragic
case was the quality assurance in place
what happened was there a complaint from
the school what did Governors say about
it what can we learn about it in this
instance but more broadly what does the
next incarnation of inspection need to
look at because I think most people
would say we have got it out of all
proportion what role should there be for
the Union in supporting staff during
these challenging times oh you you would
pay your subscription to a trade Union
because you will want support from your
union now the reality is if you phoned
me today you're being inspected today
and you've phoned me saying I think I've
got a bad inspector here the inspection
is all falling apart what we will say is
phone offsted get one of their regional
directors put in a complaint tell us
what happens and we will then help to
try and pick up the pieces I don't know
what happened in the case of of
caversham whether that actually happened
there was certainly some problem with
the quality assurance I think because
the draft report had at the very least a
pretty crass statement about what had
happened to the Head teacher I think
ofsted should answer some questions in
terms of was the quality assurance not
in place but your your question what do
we do as a trade Union we're there to
help you and to support you as best we
can in what is one of the most stressful
periods through the whole process
through the process as far as we can but
we won't be in the school with you but
we will be on the end of a phone if you
need us to to support you but you'll be
there while people are waiting for the
report to conclude absolutely right yeah
that's important what do you think
happened
so I don't know what happened she had
the support she needed obviously I don't
know all and all I would do is to go
back to what the Samaritans say of us
always being cautious about describing
one thing as the cause of what might
have happened in a suicide so it is
absolutely clear that the pressure and
the humiliation that even even as a you
know the seasoned veteran head teacher
for 15 years in a big school
if you get a great saying leadership and
management is inadequate you take that
personally if your school topples from
one rating to another you take that
personally that isn't a fault of ofsted
it's a fault of us putting too much
emphasis on ofsted we have to get it
back in proportion sure I mean the
Clue's in the title it's your job to
make sure that the school runs it is but
it if you're the head of a small primary
school and Leadership is being called as
inadequate because of something which
may have been nothing to do with the
curriculum may have been nothing to do
with teaching it may have been something
to do with safeguarding and health and
safety none of which is to say those
things aren't important but you can feel
nothing but a sense of personal guilt
and personal shame around that now what
you would hope is that a combination of
your governess and supporting you a
combination of a better complaints
procedure than ofsted has got at the
moment they acknowledge we need a better
compliance procedure because at the
moment it feels like ofsted's word
against yours Austin rules the winners
on that but also trade unions support
all of those things need to be in place
this I think is a wake-up call around
how we use inspection I think we need to
get it back into all proportion and the
interesting thing I'm a member of the
times education commission uh and the
the might of the times did a huge survey
of parents parents don't trust the
judgments you know if you if you send
your child to an outstanding school but
your child's coming home every day in
the history teacher never marks the
books you're not going to think that's
an outstanding school you're going to
get pretty terrible for history
well in that case why don't we take
those judgments away and why don't we
tell you what the school is doing well
and not doing well and that's what
Labor's saying is what the Church of
England is saying is what Independent
Schools are saying is taking away the
overall judgment that I think would take
some of the pressure off and still do
what we want inspection to do hold a
mirror up and tell us how good our
schools are good to see you as always
thanks very much thank you
if you have been affected by this story
and want to talk to someone you can call
the Samaritans free
116-123-116-123 or you can email Joe at
samaritans.org
returning now to a major new report
which has found the Metropolitan Police
is institutionally racist sexist and
homophobic testy interview with Sir Mark
Rowley about that who's the Met
commissioner earlier this hour let's
bring in now former superintendent
nazrit metab who quit the force in 2020
alleging racist and sexist
discrimination Hi how are you it's good
to see you hi good morning um how
damning is this report for them
extremely damning what bear in this case
he's done she's held a mirror to the
workforce and what you see what they
should see is that they're
institutionally racist misogynistic and
homophobic and it's a police service
that's lost its way shocking and it's
devastating for the people of London she
still thinks that smart world is the
best person for the job I think under
these circumstances because he's new he
has the will he's not new though is he I
mean no you're absolutely right but new
in the role of commissioner because he
was just a missionary yes absolutely and
I actually served under him because he
was under specialist operations to be
honest um I didn't have that much
dealing with him well that was a body's
worth it it certainly was so um I would
say that he has the will the
determination but does he have the power
because they're in special measures on
top of that they've got all this to sort
out and time will tell but he needs
support and he needs to have far more
powers to be able to do this
um it could be broken up the match do
you think that would be a good idea is
it just too big I think if they don't
accept those recommendations and to
start to see how he's not going to
accept that they're institutionally
racist yeah which to me well it's not a
pick a mix is it really it's not
negotiable he either accepts the whole
report in his holistic form and if they
don't and MET Management do not accept
it then I think the fullback should be
that there should be a disbanding of the
mayor because you can't pick and choose
it's non-negotiable baroness Casey has
been there a year looking at data and
the data is devastating the communities
have been telling um the Metropolitan
Police Service that they've
institutionally racist women has been
have been saying that they're
misogynistic and now the workforce has
told it and now the data and the
evidence and if you don't accept it then
I think that it should be uh disbanded
how does he start to rebuild the force
he's got the support the Home Secretary
he's got the support of Dominic Robb the
Justice secretary I'll hear what the
mayor of London has to say in the next
hour what does he need to do to start to
rebuild it you say to accept the report
in full he told me on the program this
morning he's not going to do that so
what are the options are there well the
options are then that they put somebody
else into power that does accept it and
that's willing to do everything Casey
said it's a disaster from the start K if
you start to pick uh you know if you
start to pick and choose and think I'll
take recommendation one but actually I
won't accept that for me as I said
that's negotiating non-negotiable and he
has to he has to be convinced to accept
it if he doesn't then the alternative
that he is removed and somebody else
comes is head of the Metropolitan Police
Service that will accept those
recommendations and move forward if
that's not possible then I think an
independent body should be brought in to
look at it and to dismantle it it's a
big beast and they do specialisms very
well as we know
um in terms of putting investing money
in that but Frontline policing
neighborhood policing has been neglected
so those are the things that they really
do need to invest in and specialisms
need to be hyped off and what needs to
happen is local for policing police
should just be focusing on local
policing neighborhood policing and they
need to put Community back at the heart
of policing okay it's good to talk to
you thanks very much indeed thank you
really appreciate it thank you